so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages and tonight we'll take a look at
the headlines with boris johnson's
former advisor colvier ranger
and the journalist and author christina
patterson great to see you both we'll
speak in a moment first of all let's
check out
those front pages shall we starting with
the sunday times reporting that the
prime minister's former chief advisor
dominic cummings
is preparing a dossier of evidence that
will try to blame boris johnson for the
tens of thousands of deaths
during the second wave of the pandemic
well it's the same story
on the front of the mail on sunday
number 10 rages
at nasty sexist cummings
the telegraph says number 10 fears
cummings bombshell
dossier in the observer johnson faces
mps fury over downing street sleaze
claims
oops the star says the prime minister's
credibility has been totally blown to
shreds
after his former adviser goes nuclear
the sunday mirror leads with concerns
that boris johnson is risking national
security
by using an unsecured phone the sunday
express
featured an exclusive on the front page
about our return to normal life
saying the vaccination rollout will save
us from another winter
lock down
and with that we're joined tonight by
cool via ranger and christina
paterson good to see you both so dominic
cummings dominating the papers
once again christina i'm sure you've got
something to say
about all of this nuclear dom they're
calling him and the sunday times has
this
interesting take on the whole thing that
he's going to blame the prime minister
for the covid death toll apparently he's
got a huge
dossier he's been keeping all sorts of
notes and he's ready to let
rip well
i don't think any of this looks
particularly savory to the british
public but i'm afraid
this story is the most important in of
the whole lot because
the fact is that boris johnson is to
blame for our enormous death toll
you could argue that in the first few
weeks
anyone would have made mistakes you
could also argue that to miss
five cobra meetings looks as the lady
bracknell might have said
rather careless that's putting it
lightly
but what we do know is that by the time
by september actually the scientists
were
strongly recommending a circuit breaker
and we know that boris johnson refused
to do that we
also know that various libertarian
scientists like carl
gennahan and sinetra gupta and anders
tegnal
were rallied to the cause by rishi sunak
who
persuaded boris johnson who already as
we know has
pretty libertarian instincts in spite of
having nearly died of covet himself
to not have that circuit breaker and
then to go ahead
with christmas plans having said that it
would be inhuman to cancel christmas
so boris johnson is absolutely to blame
for the 150 000 deaths or at least a
very high percentage of those deaths
and amidst all the rest of the uh
accusations that dominic cummings has
made about lack of ethics lack of
integrity he's a fine person to speak it
has to be said
but i think this is vitally important
because people have lost loved ones
who did not need to die and would not
have died
if boris johnson had not made the
decisions he made
so this is incredibly important and the
sunday times in fact did a superb
investigation into this
a book called failure's estate which i
reviewed for the sunday times a few
weeks ago
and it has a damning and utterly damning
account
of the government's management of the
polemic overseen
and responsible for uh the
responsibility being boris johnson's
okay so those are the charges outlaid uh
in the sunday times colvir how worried
will the prime minister be
about all of this i may just correct but
that's not all the charges laid out in
the sunday times that's probably
christina's charges on
a lot of those factors and to be honest
you know this
is an um
[Music]
having a go uh about decisions that
when we look at the pandemic as a whole
i think if you go to the british people
right now and say to them how do you
think this government and this prime
minister
has handled the pandemic yes they'll
identify problems yes they'll say that
there have been issues
and obviously every death of the 127 000
or so there's been has been a tragedy
for those individuals and their families
but when we look at it in the global
scale and particularly when we see
i know we'll talk about india later but
where other countries even closer to
home
places like france germany have been
saying their presence has been saying
they're envious of where
the british people and the british
government has got us in managing this
pandemic under this prime minister and
the decisions this government has taken
i think people will say there's a
balanced view to be taken but also
welcome i'm just going to say cool very
interesting you say that because there
is a poll out tonight an opinion poll
which puts the tories up to 11 but it
also says that
two out of every five people think boris
johnson is corrupt
well i look i i think there's a matter
of timing here and there's a
you know this impact of um
what seems to be hearsay whatsapp there
isn't any real evidence and to be honest
look
i i've worked with a lot of people in
government i still do
um i see and a lot of people agree that
our
civil service and our government as a
whole is probably the most ethical
and of the highest standard globally in
terms of how contracts are issued and
uh the government works so i i know
there's some stories at the moment
about text messages and then we talk
about um
sir james dyson you know the prime
minister being accused of
inappropriate contact to a a world
leading renowned industrious who had a
time of the need for this country and
the peoples offering his services and
wanted some help
to get that done of course the prime
minister will help his first
duty of care is to the british people
and to do whatever he can
to make sure he can help and protect
rich people so look i think in the
context the british public will see this
and say
this is not serious news about how the
prime minister
has handled the pandemic and i think uh
uh thor
and uh people have heard enough about
dominic cummings and probably
uh his behavior previously and they make
up their own mind about how reliable a
witness
uh he is okay uh christina uh front page
of the observer johnson faces mp's fury
over downing street
claims colvier they're saying this
government uh is ethical and has uh
high standards
well i i mean i can only lead off i mean
you know you just can't
you can't take that view seriously i'm
afraid um
in terms of the current management of
the pandemic i think compared to many
european leaders
it you know they got their act together
we've been in lockdown for months which
has had a very heavy toll
not least by children um many people are
paying an extremely heavy price for it
but
it was necessary because we went so late
we didn't have the circuit break and we
went so late into this in the autumn and
then the kent variant was allowed to
spread and here we are
but no one can deny that the vaccine
program has been a huge success
and thank goodness for that and the nhs
has shown
what it is which is an amazing
organization that
has incredible logistical abilities and
we also have kate bingham
to thank for her superb work in
uh you know hedge betting and and
choosing some vaccines that have paid
off moderna pfizer and most of all
astrazeneca so
congratulations to all those people
involved and thank goodness it looks as
though that
is on the way to leading us out of this
pandemic but in terms of integrity you
have got to be joking you have got to be
joking everybody knows
boris johnson was always known to be a
liar he's been sacked from several jobs
for lying he's a pathological liar
he consistently lies dominic cummings
knows he lies
um i've no idea how truthful or reliable
dominic cummings
is clearly he behaved appallingly last
year and his story about
testing his eyesight and so and tested
the credulity of you know frankly the
most credulous person so
this does look like rats fighting in a
sack
but when it comes to using taxpayers
money to renovate
your personal flat which seems to be one
of the key accusations here
the government says that the prime
minister paid for himself well we
haven't yet had any evidence of that but
we there was plenty of talk before about
getting tory donors to pay for this
and i i would be very surprised if
dominic cummings doesn't have some
documented evidence to to back up his
claims on that i think
i think number 10 is quaking in its
boots now and has good reason to because
i'm sure that dominic cummings has a lot
of whatsapp messages or text messages or
whatever that will back up a fair degree
of what he said yeah he said
as much didn't he in his thousand word
blog call fear let's have a quick look
at the front of the the mail number 10
rages at nasty sexist
cummings uh they're saying that he's
been briefing against uh
carrie simons i mean uh corvia
uh where do you think all of this goes
next and why do you think the prime
minister chose to pick a fight with
dominic comings of all people
yeah i would say you know that the
number 10 machine probably doesn't need
to sink to the level of engaging
in this conversation i i think you know
as we've been discussing this is an
individual
who for all his brilliance and you know
he has some brilliance and some amazing
capabilities
but operates in a way that isn't
collegiate isn't probably
team based um and these kinds of
conversations and the kinds of
conversations that he's having
are not really at the front center of
the minds of the british public they're
not what people are
genuinely interested in and there isn't
any evidence about a lot of the sort of
gossip about how was
a flat paid for even though uh number 10
have said the prime minister paid for
this himself
you know we're talking about how the
prime minister paid for the curtains
when
there are much more important things
going on in this country as we all know
and across the world
that the prime minister and the
government have been dealing with and
have got their entire focus on and i
think really
yes this story is going to cause a storm
um at the moment in the
uh tomorrow's papers but i don't think
it's going to last i don't think
this particular story is going to last
because i don't think there actually is
the evidence and i don't see why
um the labour party and secure some are
asking for an inquiry into these things
what are they actually asking an inquiry
for you know who paid
for number 10's curtains well the prime
minister said he will i'm sure you
provide the evidence that says he did
and really is that what the leader of a
majesty's opposition should be asking
about when we are
are dealing with a global pandemic and
we really need to get the british people
and the economy back on their feet
yeah he says that sunlight is the best
disinfectant so we'll wait and see um
we'll leave dominic cummings there i
know we could talk about this
all evening but we must leave it there
because
meanwhile india is setting another
global record
daily for coving 19 infections we're
discuss
discussing that and plenty more after
this short break do join us
hello again welcome back uh part two the
press preview with me boris johnson's
former advisor coolview ranger and the
journalist and author christina
patterson
uh corville let's turn our attention to
india then front page of the sunday
times i mean we've been
reporting from there all day today and
it is incredibly distressing isn't it
oxygen running out people dying on the
pavement
outside hospitals and as the sunday
times reports they're bracing themselves
for half a million infections
a day yes it's harrowing and i'm sure
we've all seen the pictures as well and
it just goes to show if you don't get a
grip
of this pandemic if the political
structures if the thinking
if the management isn't there um just
what can happen now india obviously
a vast population uh billion billion
four plus people and i personally i'm
sure many people
we're always worried about countries and
obviously our friends and family in
india but countries like india and their
capability to be able to manage this
uh covert pandemic especially if it got
a grip now
it appeared in the first wave you know
india seemed to get through it but i've
also heard you know the figures
weren't quite accurate in terms of what
happened in the first wave
now and actually having gone through
that first wave and i say this having
spoken to colleagues over the week
in india to and i'd be asking them you
know what really is going on
and i had colleagues in delhi who are
saying there's panic
the hospitals have just can't cope the
health system is collapsing but other
parts
chennai uh things a little bit under
control so
vast country huge issues but i think
what the real concern here is
what can the global community do it was
good to hear
um i think from the prime minister but
the government looking to provide
support maybe even ventilators
heading out to india but i think this is
where
the next stage of this pandemic and
management of it at a global scale is so
important how do we come together
as an international community to help
india to help brazil to help turkey
those countries are finding it ever so
hard
where they haven't maybe got the mature
health systems
and need that support as well as putting
pressure on their politicians locally
to ensure that they are doing the right
things because i do hear unfortunately
things like the cost of medicine um
if you know people and if you have the
money you potentially could get
the things you need but even that is now
sort of running out it appears when the
supply chains are just failing
yeah so a lot to be done oxygen being
bought on the black market you know for
four
times what it would uh normally cost uh
christina i mean
it is incredibly depressing well it's
utterly heartbreaking but the thing that
i
torments me actually is how populous
leaders
like modi and like bolsonaro
can hold the lives of their people so
cheap
i mean we've known what this virus is we
know what it does we know how contagious
it is
we know that you have to have social
distancing in order to
control it and what has nodey done he
has
modi done he has held mass rallies he
was boasting about the number of people
i think only about a week ago at one of
his mass rallies he has
uh not he has encouraged religious
festivals
mass festivals to go ahead only
a madman or a sociopath would do such a
thing during a pandemic
and the same had was true has been true
for bolsonaro and the same was true for
donald trump who thank goodness
is not in power anymore so of course we
should
do what we can to help and it is tragic
that the health care system
is not up to the challenge but the
reason the challenge exists is because
a populist leader does not value the
lives of the people
he was elected to lead and that is an
absolute tragedy
we've just got about a minute left but i
want to touch on this story as well cole
there it's on the front of the sunday
telegraph just uh talk us through this
if you would wipe
non-crime hate allegations says home
secretary pretty patel
well i think this is an interesting and
probably you know something that a lot
of people would welcome
view that if there are allegations about
uh crimes against people that and
they're not proven to be
um uh hate crimes that they shouldn't be
held in the record against individuals
because we all know that you know the
stains that can be provided on people
who
who are accused of things that then they
weren't found guilty of
and i think this is another thing that
uh the home secretary is looking closely
at
because of the uh defamation
the issues that people have that impact
on their lives and the impact of their
families
when they are accused of things
inappropriately now i i've
known people that this has happened to
and seen the impact
on their lives and it's terrible so you
know i welcome this
review by the home secretary on this
issue quick thought from you christina
yeah i think this may be the first time
in my life i've actually agreed with
pretty patel
i think that um i i think that
hate incidents you know you have to
define them very carefully and
there are things that you know you can
say that might be classified
as hate uh or that some people think are
hate
which are just a disagreement and a
difference of opinion and
if you are found to broken the law
that's one thing but if you have been
found not to broken the law i
i don't see why your reputation should
be solid or where that should stay
on your record so i agree with pretty
patel and i don't know if i'll ever say
those words again
okay christina covey thank you both